With all of these considerations, let's imagine we're working on a traffic light system.
We have three colors in here, red, amber, and green.
Now, we have a little piece of code in here,
which impacted the traffic based on the traffic light.
Let's assume this is part of some traffic stimulation.
So, if the light is red, then the traffic should stop.
If the light is amber, then the traffic should prepare to stop.
And if the light is green, then the traffic should go.
Now, being good programmers, we always assume that something goes wrong
if the light is neither red nor amber nor green,
which in principle shouldn't happen, which due to some bug could happen.
What should be here where the question mark is? I'll give you four choices.
First, we print out "This can't happen," on the console
in the hope that somebody will eventually see it.
Second, we raise an assertion exception.
We knew that the program will immediately abort.
Third, we write down assert false thereby clearly documenting that this is not expected.
Last option, you write down pass, which is a Python statement, which does nothing at all.
After all, this bug in the traffic light may well eventually go away
at the next cycle when we actually go back into some defined state.
Which of these four is the best option to go down here
considering the pros and cons about assertion that we see over to you.